all kinds of crazy things not everything
but all kinds of crazy things that we
can imagine could or will become real
[Music]
well that's why I'm so fascinated with
the speed part of it yes because it's
sort of like well somewhere maybe in
China but somewhere there's gonna be an
island of dr. Moreau sort of thing where
just some scientist who doesn't you know
who just wants to do whatever he can
with you and you know let the
consequences be damned we'll go ahead
and do it and it won't you know for
years that could exist and no one will
know and then you know the more
responsible scientists will constantly
be playing catch-up and then that also
sort of brings me to the law part of
this because we are starting sort of to
discuss laws around this here a little
bit barely barely I mean I remember when
George W Bush was sort of talking about
some of this we're related to stem cells
and that sort of thing but how much of
this do you think will come down to just
what countries will sort of allow it
more versus what scientists are just
gonna do with them yeah it's a great
question it's an essential question
that's the race because the science is
moving forward exponentially you're
exactly right it was not a surprise that
the the first I write about this in the
book that the first application of using
CRISPR gene editing on humans happened
in China
I always said that's where it's going to
happen it's not a surprise that now it's
in Russia that there's a biologist there
who's saying he has five people lined up
to have more genetically engineered
babies and this happens all this
technology exists within the context of
our societies and so there are some
societies that are Beit better regulated
in these areas I always hold up the
United Kingdom as kind of the gold
standard they have a national health
care system which makes it much more it
much easier to just spread rationality
in the system where we had in the u.s.
we have this kind of this chaotic system
of a system of a system is the part of
the problem in my audience it's not a
big regulation guys so it's part of the
problem though that even if you have
regulation well done well intentioned
all that that in a way that will slow
down certain advancements where then the
bad guys let's say or the kooky
scientist who who don't have those
ethical dilemmas yes we'll just keep
making jumps in a faster faster way yeah
but we don't it's not unlike regulation
is good or bad we need the right amount
of regulation to incentivize the
outcomes that we want and especially in
an area like this where we're talking
about the future of human life the you
you talked about where does life begin
at conception which is a very legitimate
issue a lot of people feel emotional
about it and the people who are saying
life begins at conception they're not
saying life begins at conception but
let's have no regulations and life
begins at conception for me they're
saying what we need to have a regulatory
system by laws so to determine what
people can and can't do and I may
disagree with with some of the goals
that they're setting but I think we're
all agreeing that this needs to be you
this is life and it has to be regulated
and we don't want scientists out there
just experimenting on humans which is
what happened in in China right and so
that's what I'm saying I'm with you on
that but that we can't regulate all
countries what we need to do with like
if any society decide that we're just
gonna opt out of this of this technology
like opting out of the genetics
revolution is opting out of national
competitiveness in the 21st century
like if you do it you can do it but you
are just going to be like you're not
going to have a competitive economy
because this is the future it's it is
you're gonna be like when we find those
random tribes somewhere yeah which is
great and they're probably happier than
we are they're working out you know our
steps a day that's a whole topic so what
we need to do is we need to find that
that balance within our within our
societies and it's a it's good to have
that balance because like with the
United Kingdom they're very well
regulated they have cutting-edge science
but the public is on board with the
science and so we United says we have
incredible science we have the best
basic science in the world but there's
this total mismatch between the science
that's racing for it and the general
public which is kind of afraid and
is is caution why we're doing this
exactly no I know and so we need to find
a way of bringing those people together
now I'm going to do an interview on newt
gingrich's radio show and I'm so
committed to engaging with religious
communities evangelical communities
conservative communities because it's
like it wouldn't it be terrible say oh
like oh no this is my truth that's your
truth we can't even talk to each other
that's the the foundation of society but
you're absolutely right there are some
places that are going to be that already
are less regulated or maybe well
regulated based on a different set of
values you can imagine a place like
North Korea they said we want to leave
the leaders why do we want to stay in
power forever and so we'd like to
engineer certain outcomes that will have
a Plato's Republic model or have the
leaders and then we'll have the
followers and we'll select their embryos
or maybe even do some basic gene editing
to determine certain outcomes and so
there's a race and there's a race
between societies but there's also a
race to see can we build some kind of
normative global system that can at
least bring us all together with a
process and there's a lot of examples of
failure but there's if there's some
examples whether its nuclear weapons
chemical weapons biological weapons even
climate change where we've not succeeded
but we've done certainly better than
worse and the entire we talked about
telling stories I mean international law
is a story the concept of human rights
is a story and we've sold those stories
pretty well and that's what we need to
do and then that's why we need to work
on the individual level everyone needs
to be educated on the national level we
need smart laws and we need political
leaders who are engaged on this issue
which is is hardly the case now and on
an international system where we need to
move towards having processes that can
bring us together and over time develop
noir norms and regulations and laws okay
so we sort of understand the inequity
let's say between the way certain
nations are going to deal with this and
the way certain individual scientists
are going to deal with this let's jump
into that religious porn end of it for a
moment so I'm glad you're gonna go talk
to a new
I've got him coming on in the oh good
and he said look it's interesting to
talk to a Republican who I think you
know basically I think has a pretty
decent understanding yeah I ins but
comes from a religious perspective as
well okay that's fine is a it's
essential what do we do not talk to each
other so so when you talk to it yeah
nude or even even not to make it so
specifically about about nude but when
you talk to people of faith yeah I think
the first roadblock you're gonna come
against is they're just gonna say you're
playing God I mean yeah sure you hear
this all the time so how do you how do
you counter that or how do you swage
their fears yeah yeah so first the first
thing is acknowledging it's like I get
that fear I share that fear I mean
whether it's playing God or messing with
complex systems that we don't fully
understand I mean this is the this is a
hubris t'k Act we are just one little
species in a world of may millions of
species like who says that we are the
ones who get to recreate life and so I
get it but if you believe that is okay
for humans to apply technology to change
our environments the question is and
should we or shouldn't we because that's
what we do that's why we're here that's
what medicine is that's what agriculture
is I mean we live in a world that we
have transformed through our art
technology the question is what are the
uses of that technology that we are that
we're comfortable with and I get that
this issue of abortion is very difficult
it's very painful for for people and I'm
not a proponent of abortion mm-hm I just
feel that a woman should have the right
within limits to dictate what happens to
her own body I don't think this this
date basically can enforce slavery on
women to force them to carry children on
behalf of the state which is essentially
what what what it would be but like even
with the people who are the the corn
quit pro-life people in the context of
the debates that we just had in Alabama
mmm-hmm there were people who were
that people in the state Senate in
Alabama they very consciously decided to
leave IVF out of that legislation mm-hmm
so if you believe that life begins at
conception when that sperm fertilizes
the egg that is life and that's
inviolable you would say well we should
include IVF right it's been they're not
doing it because in the every community
when you see these parents whether
they're high-risk parents or older
parents or soon just normal parents who
are having children through IVF it's the
miracle of life and so the quote from
from one of the Alabama senators well
we're not applying this doesn't apply to
those fertilized eggs in a dish we're
talking about about about embryos inside
of a woman's body so that's a real
disconnect there you could call it a
disconnect but I'm not calling it a disc
I'm saying it's a recognition that this
stuff is really complicated and if we
just say I have this absolute position
and and I'm just gonna stick to it I
think that's going to like I want to
look for to say all right well you have
recognized that because you are pro-life
you recognize that you want to protect
embryos and we may have political
differences but I respect yours and you
want to protect the miracle of life of
these these people in your communities
who are having kids through IVF that
they otherwise wouldn't have and so I
just think we have to work towards
finding some kind of con are we ever
going to completely agree no but no no
that's not a standard in a democracy
it's not you have to agree on everything
is that how do we rebuild a place where
we can at least communicate with each
other and try to find as much common
ground as possible so there's so many
ways I could go with this yeah and I
have a zillion sci-fi movies rattling in
their head yes suddenly I had something
about Star Wars in there related to you
basically a clone army we'd started
having this genetically modified group
of humans versus we haven't even got
into robotics at all never but AI
Androids and they're gonna sort of be
rising but let me let me hold
yeah for for just a sec what about the
economic portion of this which is that
once these technologies become more
ubiquitous and more people can afford
them and then then then they're just
sort of out there and some of that
mainstream but obviously like every
other technology like a flat-screen
television you know people that have the
means will start using them and that
basically we're gonna sort of have two
paths for humans there'll be sort of
these super humans who will be able to
deal with all of these things and take
advantage of these technologies and then
you'll have the regular old suckers like
us right now that can't do it and that
what what we're gonna do with that how
we're gonna sort of bridge that divide
it's it's a really essential essential
quite a few different ways of answering
it one is that's one possibility and if
we let that happen
shame on us because the technology isn't
requiring that outcome it's the way we
have decided to organize ourselves so in
a country like Israel where IVF is
included in the National Health Plan you
don't have these these these equity
issues because everybody has access and
if you have a system where you're doing
that it actually would pay for itself
because we're going to be able to
prevent huge numbers of genetic diseases
that are costing us many many hundreds
of billions of dollars so that's an
organizational issue no I always say
that if people are worried about genetic
inequality in the future as we should be
we can wait until the future comes to
say like AHA this was where you look at
the world today and say jeez there's so
much inequality today average person kid
born in the Central African Republic is
born essentially brain damaged because
of mountain ternal malnutrition in the
context of the civil war and so there's
no difference in terms of outcome
between a genetically enhanced person
and me or my kids and my kids and a kid
born in the Central African Republic
there's still that same differential but
if we're okay with that today if we're
not living those values today how can we
sell but in the future we want to live
those values when we are the people in
the Central African Republic and then
the second point I'll quickly make is we
all have these
for powers that once seemed like magic
so we're all and most hopefully
immunized or most of us are immunized
not how much anymore it's like a
superpower
yeah and it's a zoom round that
everybody has so there's also a cost
issue with this
okay so let's so basically there's a
that's the political elevators this
that's sort of the so what do you do I
mean how do you how do you get
politicians to get on board things that
are such big ideas that you know
politicians when they talk about
anything now we've been dumbed down to
the point where it's like yeah you're
gonna mention CRISPR and it's gonna make
sense anyway like how do you actually
get me a political elite to be able to
deal with this anonymous way then the
honest answer is I don't know yeah I'm
just trying here the here are the things
that at least I'm trying to do one is
I'm trying to help people get educated
and so with this book I've written it's
it's really at a level that anybody can
can understand and I want to just bring
people into the in like it once you have
basic information we're all equals
because we're all humans and everyone
has to say to where I'm doing a lot of
outreach to political leaders we've
offered the copies of the e-book for
free to any member of parliament of any
country in the whole world
talking with actually brad sherman is a
congressman from los angeles and and
others about congressional hearings in
the paperback version of hacking dharam
which is coming out in april we're gonna
have a short political guide in the end
with some some pointers but have it
questions to ask for your political
leaders and i'm doing this this work in
in geneva but all of that amounts to
nothing in the sense that what we need
is we need eight an explosion like
everybody we need on a popular level
people need to be seized with issues
what kind of like it's happened with
climate change i mean climate change ten
years ago was a non-issue and now you
know people are whether it's not using
plastic straws or you're marching or
whether people get that this is an issue
people get that they want to have their
voices heard we need to have that happen
and with issues of genetics and now will
at least begin to put this on the radar
of political leaders but then we need to
educate political leaders like we need
to have outreach and this is i talked
about this in
the book you every movement has to start
somewhere it has to start from this
little little hopeless place where like
there's this huge problem and there's
just a few a few people but if we need
it's a it's a political issue and the
issue the challenge is ten years from
now this is going to be the biggest
issue in the world everyone's going to
be talking about they're going to be
people marching I think there's a
potential of violence because the people
who are if you're worried about
genetically modified crops now how are
you gonna feel about gently modified
humans so but why wait ten years until
this is like an exploding crisis to have
a conversation about one of the things
that we should be doing now cuz big
decisions are being made every day yeah
so when you talk about genetically
modified humans I'll go to one of the
sci-fi movies did you ever see the
island I can't believe I'm gonna quote a
Michael Bay movie no but it's it's I
think it was maybe it was a philip k
dick story right but basically the idea
being that these sort of rich elite
people could clone themselves and so
that if any F at any point they got into
a car accident or had a disease that
they basically had all the parts
available and then of course what
happens is the clones believe that they
are human and right that's what the
right the debate comes about but but all
that's not that far from what be cut
could become reality right nearly as a
science fiction writer and recognize
that we live in this world of
exponential change where are our sense
of the speed of change is too
conservative because we understand it
that just because the way our brains
function by looking backwards mmm-hmm
whereas change is happening going
forwards is going to be a lot a lot
faster all kinds of crazy things not
everything but all kinds of crazy things
that we can imagine could or will become
real and so that's so there are a lot of
different scenarios certainly human
biology is extremely complex and so it's
going to take us a long time to
understand more of this incredible
complexity but our the this the
complexity of our biology has been
roughly consistent for millions of years
but the sophistication of our tools is
on a J curve and so we are going to be
using big data analytics and all of
these other incredibly powerful tools
to understand ourselves and we're going
to be able to look under the hood of
what it means to be human there will
still be this wonderful mystery yeah but
we're going to know a lot more we're
gonna have to figure out how to use that
knowledge in ways that doesn't undermine
our humanity but makes us individually
and collectively better that could be
the ending but I want to go a little bit
more so going back to what I mentioned
before this sort of somewhat silly Star
Wars thing but this idea of clones that
we can genetically modify their
conditions and all of these things and
now you have AI growing is there sort of
a split within the futurist community of
what people think is maybe one is more
the future than the other or something
like that there are some people who are
that that it's genetically engineered
humans and their summit is going to be
AI and in my very very strong view it
can't be one or the other it's it's
humans plus AI garry kasparov writes
about this and that's that is the thing
cuz we are humans are incredible our
brain is so unbelievably almost
magically sophisticated all the things
that they can do are just so way beyond
the possibility even you know even of
our most advanced AIS and so we need to
find ways that we will work together
genetics revolution is the AI revolution
there would be no way that without our
AI and big data analytics that we could
even begin to to decode the incredible
complexity of our of our biology so the
two really need to work together and
that'll be the story of the 21st century
is to figure out what a what do humans
do that machines can't do and what a
machines do the humans can't do or just
if are better at the Diamonds and how do
we pull those capabilities together and
then with these massively powerful
capabilities how do we try to build some
guardrails to make sure that our
technology is used to advance our best
values rather than undermine them
okay so we'll end on this I'll give you
the scariest question I possibly could
which is
twenty years from now if if the 98% that
you usually focus on good stuff at the
talks right if that really works paint
me what that future looks like and then
we'll go to the other sure so that one
is we're going to be living longer we're
going to be living healthier we're going
to have all kinds of information about
future risks and potentials and we're
going to use that in a positive way to
inform our lives if we have risks a down
the line we're going to be working to
minimize those risks we're going to
change the way that we make babies we're
going to increasingly move from
conception through sex to conception
through IVF followed by embryo screening
right now in the u.s. we have about two
percent of kids are born through IVF in
Japan it's five percent in Norway and
Denmark it's ten percent those numbers
are always going to go up and still
until we see procreation by sex is
something that is not natural and then
we're also going to be I can't believe
I'd even mentioned this whole time we're
also gonna be then growing humans in
labs too you know that's a debate now so
there this this whole movement for
artificial wombs mm-hmm
there's a lot that happens emotionally
and biologically we've seen a mother and
a baby but certainly it's it's working
for sheep and so they're basically the
core point is that biology is at play we
have this sense though we I know what
volatile biology is because I'm a human
and my parents were humans but a lot of
these things are just at play I mean we
were single-cell organisms and now we're
this and we're going to be something
else and that's something else will be
impacted by our technology just like you
are our digestive system has been guided
by fire like FISA allows us to digest
things that otherwise we couldn't and so
we are like that is where we're going
and then just this this 20 years story
so we're gonna be on better healthcare
moving away from sex from conception
through sex and we're going to be begin
selecting future children based on
health outcomes and other information
about traits now give me the 2% we screw
this thing up what are we looking at we
are attacking each other that there's a
level of social cohesion
that is required for this technology to
advance in ways that benefit everybody
one of the reasons why we're having so
many problems here in the United States
is that we had this economic change so
we had this change in in basically the
role of capital in society so capital
was overvalued and labor was undervalued
we allowed this small group of people to
amass just a disproportionately
disproportionate and inappropriate
amount of power and then everybody else
maybe they couldn't articulate all the
reasons and does have this something hey
I'm getting screwed over hmm
and I'm gonna fight back and so if this
powerful technology if we don't handle
it in a responsible way we're gonna be
at each other's throats we're going to
have elites we're saying you know screw
this like my mission in life is to
create advantages and confer advantages
to the to my children I have more in
common with people who are wanting to do
that in other countries all around the
world then I do with these other people
in my country who are just causing
there's a pain in my ass and they're
demanding things and they're fighting
against things that I want so I'm just
leaving I mean my crops are basically
they're gonna have to build Elysium or
something or something or just you know
you very just you know take have an
island do it in the Caribbean or or
whatever so if we're not careful on
these technologies could destroy our
societies and that's why I mean this is
a conversation it's teed up by science
but it's the core pillar is values I
mean that's what this is all about I
would love to continue this yes we got a
wrap but as you may know I go off the
grid for August so today we're taping
this right now at the end of July right
and I'm disappearing no technology no
phone and nothing electronic
and so you've teed me up for so much
good stuff to think about where you
going I hope you think I'm not telling
people but I'm just I'm disappearing and
there will be nothing electronic and
it's it's so important because we're
talking about this this technology and
technology it does so many wonderful
things but at the core if we lose the
essence of what it just means to be a
human how
the mountains it's like that's
everything yeah I've thoroughly enjoyed
this I hope you'll come back to I will
to get you back in the prediction I I
would love I'll come back in my the
paperback version of hacking Darwin's
coming out in April of next year and so
I'd love to come back when that happens
done and all right thank you very much
and for more on Jamie you can follow him
on Twitter at Jamie Metzl and if you
enjoy conversations like these don't
forget to subscribe and click the bell
so they actually get notified of the
videos thanks for watching
[Music]